The Mighty Ducks might never have made it
to the screen if weren't for Wayne Gretzky's
trade to the LA Kings in 1988, a move that
sparked an increased interest in ice hockey
throughout Los Angeles — and didn't go unnoticed
by Hollywood execs.
Steven Brill's script about a down-and-out
lawyer taking over a useless pee-wee team
was picked up by Disney, and the Mouse House
quickly set about preparing sequels after
the box office success of the 1992 original.
Coach Gordon Bombay and his ragtag roster
of players triple-deked their way into pop
culture history.
"Ducks never say die.
Ever seen a duck fight?
No way.
Why?
'Cause the other animals are afraid"
But you can't play pee-wee forever, and Bombay's
ducklings are now all grown up — and not
all of them found Hollywood success after
leaving the nest.
Emilio Estevez
The role of Gordon Bombay allowed Emilio Estevez
to shake off the Brat Pack tag he carried
throughout the '80s.
He'd already attempted to move away from coming-of-age
dramedies with his turn as Billy the Kid in
the Young Guns movies, though Bombay was his
first real grown-up character.
He carried on acting into the late '90s and
early '00s, but now spends much of his time
writing and directing.
He still holds Gordon Bombay close to his
heart, however, which he proved in 2015 when
he live-tweeted support for the Anaheim Ducks
during their playoff showdown with the Chicago
Blackhawks.
Joshua Jackson
The part of championship-winning penalty scorer
Charlie Conway was originally supposed to
be played by a young Jake Gyllenhaal, who
was offered the part on the back of his performance
as Billy Crystal's son 1991's City Slickers.
Joshua Jackson stepped in when Jake couldn't
take it, which kickstarted a career that's
grown to include five-season stints on Dawson's
Creek and Fringe.
Jackson made his transition from movies to
TV after taking his final bow as Charlie in
1996's Mighty Ducks threequel, D3, and he
remains a man of the small screen today, starring
in Showtime's The Affair.
Elden Henson
It's hard to believe Matt Murdock's loveable
sidekick Foggy Nelson is the same guy that
played hulking enforcer Fulton Reed.
Elden Henson made his first appearance in
The Mighty Ducks when members of the team
were cornered by players from their rival
team the Hawks, dispatching the bullies with
ease.
Henson went on to be a key member of the team
and the cast over the course of the three
movies.
But when the Ducks disbanded, he struggled
to make an impact in the show biz industry,
resorting to supporting parts in such films
as The Butterfly Effect.
Henson's fortunes have a taken a turn for
the better over recent years — not only
on the big screen, when he played the part
of Pollux in the two-part Hunger Games finale,
but on television, too.
He's portrayed well-meaning lawyer Foggy in
Netflix's Daredevil, as well as in the team-up
series The Defenders.
Shaun Weiss
Before making his film debut in The Mighty
Ducks, Shaun Weiss worked on several TV shows,
including an early appearance on The Cosby
Show.
By 1992, he'd grown into a big-boned 14-year-old
and was considered a perfect fit for the role
of goalie Greg Goldberg.
"Ah I smell something."
"Goldberg!"
He went on to portray the flatulent goalie
in the Ducks sequels, taking time off between
them to star in early Ben Stiller comedy Heavyweights,
a film that went on to amass a cult following
of its own.
Weiss saw the '90s out with a four-episode
stint on Judd Apatow's Freaks and Geeks — though
the next decade wasn't kind to him, with his
most significant appearance in a feature film
coming as the unnamed bus driver in 2008's
Drillbit Taylor.
Matt Doherty
After taking the part of Lester Averman in
the Mighty Ducks movies, Matt Doherty got
another '90s classic on his resume in So I
Married an Axe Murderer.
As he approached adulthood, roles started
to dry up for Doherty, and he walked the tightrope
between supporting actor and extra.
In recent years, he's turned to TV movies
and found some success on the sci-fi small
screen scene.
Garette Henson
This young star got off to a flying start
with his movie career, appearing in ten feature
films over a six-year period.
He made his bow in Arachnophobia, for example,
but Garette Henson is perhaps best remembered
as Guy Germaine from The Mighty Ducks movies.
While he admits to enjoying a chat about the
Ducks today, being associated with the films
started to wear thin towards the end of the
decade.
He ultimately stepped away from acting to
pursue college and made a brief return to
the biz in 2007 when he played a prisoner
in The Mannsfield 12.
He's now busy working behind the lens.
Danny Tamberelli
Italian-American actor and musician Danny
Tamberelli played the role of defenseman Tommy
Duncan in The Mighty Ducks, though he didn't
return for either of the sequels.
Instead, Tamberelli opted to take on the role
of Little Pete Wrigley in Nickelodeon's The
Adventures of Pete and Pete, the role that
he's still best remembered for.
The kids' network added him to the cast of
their slimy game show Figure It Out and their
live sketch comedy All That in the late '90s,
though he departed from Nickelodeon at the
turn of the millennium and transitioned into
voice work, music, and comedy.
Nowadays Tamberelli fronts Brooklyn-based
rock band Jounce.
Jussie Smollett
Justin "Jussie" Smollett recently pulled off
a comeback worthy of the Mighty Ducks, turning
his fading career around and putting himself
firmly back on the Hollywood map.
Smollett appeared in the first Ducks movie
but didn't reprise the role of Terry Hall
in either sequel, and it wasn't until the
2010s, when landed a career-making role in
Fox's hit series Empire that things got back
on track.
Thanks to his compelling work on the celebrated
series, Ridley Scott cast him in his Prometheus
sequel Alien: Covenant and he's well on his
way to the top.
Vincent Larusso
When we first meet Adam Banks in The Mighty
Ducks, he's the star player for the Ducks'
rival team, who had to change squads due to
his fudged home address.
He was an unlikely hero for the Ducks in the
end, and Vincent Larusso portrayed Banks in
all three Mighty Ducks movies.
Larusso made a brief and unexpected return
to the big screen when he portrayed the bank
robber in the 2008 spoof Superhero Movie,
though that remains his last credit of any
note.
Today, the former Duck works as an inventory
controller for the hospitality chain Soho
House.
Brandon Adams
Otherwise known as Jesse Hall in the first
two Mighty Ducks movies, Brandon Adams was
exposed to the world of acting as a toddler
when he appeared in a number of commercials.
But his big break came when he was cast as
Zeke "Baby Bad" Michael in Michael Jackson's
Moonwalker.
He went on to work with Wes Craven in The
People Under the Stairs before nabbing the
Mighty Ducks role.
Adams always had one foot in film while the
other remained in television, however, and
he started to lean more heavily on the latter
as his career progressed.
He has some genuine '90s classics to his name,
including The Sandlot.
Marguerite Moreau
As Connie in The Mighty Ducks, Marguerite
Moreau may have inspired a lot of young girls
to break down gender norms and hit the ice.
The actress seemed to grow up pretty quickly
after the Mighty Ducks trilogy ended in 1996,
appearing as camp counselor Katie in Wet Hot
American Summer a short five years later.
A major role in Queen of the Damned followed
soon after.
But while she continued to make regular movie
appearances throughout the '00s, the parts
she was offered became increasingly unfulfilling
and she turned her attention to television.
Moreau has plied her trade in small-screen
classics such as Smallville, Parenthood, and
Mad Men and also reprised the role of Katie
in 2015 when she reunited with her Wet Hot
American Summer castmates for Netflix's prequel
series First Day of Camp.
J.D. Daniels
Even though he was a prolific child actor
in the 1990s, J.D. Daniels did not come back
to reprise the role of Peter Mark in either
of the Mighty Ducks sequels and instead went
on to win a number of new roles across a variety
of genres.
Like some of his Ducks colleagues, Daniels
moved into voiceover work, and although he
hasn't notched up an acting credit in almost
a decade, Daniels remains active in the industry,
currently working for the Actors' Equity Association.
Aaron Schwartz
Practically unrecognizable today, the broad
and bearded Aaron Schwartz has come a long
way since playing chubby prankster Dave Karp
in the first Mighty Ducks.
He joined up with fellow Duck Danny Tamberelli
for an eight-episode stint on The Adventures
of Pete and Pete, then teamed up with another
former castmate, Shaun Weiss, for Judd Apatow's
Heavyweights.
When the formerly heavyset Schwartz reappeared
after a 15-year absence from the industry
in the CW's Gossip Girl, he'd grown into a
primetime-worthy hunk.
He'll join the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
2017 when he takes on the role of Young Ego
in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2, a younger
version of Kurt Russell's character.
"Just when you think they're about to break
apart, ducks fly together!"
"Ducks, ducks, ducks, ducks!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!